Hey there it's me, Conan.
I wanna talk about something important.
Recently, we invited our fans
to recreate an episode of our show.
We did this because we thought
it would be challenging,
we thought it would be
fun, and, most important,
we thought it would be a way for people
to kill just a few hours
during the pandemic.
We received just hundreds
and hundreds of incredibly
creative entries
and we stitched them together
to make one amazing program,
DIY Conan.
We're very proud of our fans.
We're very proud of this show.
Enjoy.
♪ Do, do, do, do, do ♪
♪ Do, do, do, do ♪
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
[Andy] Coming to you from all our fans,
it's DIY Conan.
I'm Andy Richter.
Tonight, Kumail Naniani
and associate producer, Jordan Schlansky.
Now, here he is, Conan O'Brien.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
We can do it.
Thank you.
Hey, thank you.
Thank you. Please, for God sake.